welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were going to be going over the newly
released Netflix film in the shadow of
the moon the movie has a pretty
mind-bending plot to it that's full of
timey wimey wibbly-wobbly stuff so if
the clothes of the film left you
scratching your head then don't worry
because we're going to be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
it throughout this video I'll be going
over how the time travel in the film
works as well as how the effects of it
leave our characters in the final few
scenes there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to watch
it yet then I highly recommend that you
turn off now
with that out the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into our breakdown
of in the shadow of the Moon okay so in
the shadow of the Moon opens on a
devastating attack on an American city
in the year 2024 we learn through the
events of the film that an extremist
committed these bombings due to hate and
external influences that shape the
attacker into having a certain mind
state the real America movement which is
what the terrorist is behind is a clear
comment on the current extreme acts of
violence that we see going on throughout
the Western world against other races
and people of certain faiths whilst I
would normally ding a Netflix movie for
trying to be to work for its own good I
think in the shadow of the Moon has a
rather more hopeful ending and doesn't
necessarily put the blame on one thing
but rather a multitude of them making it
seem less heavy-handed in its overall
message it says that both sides are to
blame and the constant bickering between
the two leads to a civil war anyway in
order to fully understand the film you
need to come to grips with the fact that
the time-traveling character in the
movie named Raya is going back through
time starting at 2015 then 2006 1997 and
lastly 1988 eliminating people who may
have influenced the attacker throughout
their life this includes a multitude of
people such as teachers musicians bus
drivers parents friends and so on the
theory behind this is that if Riya is
able to remove all of the forces that
basically shake the terrorists into the
way that they turned out the attack that
opens the movie will have happened it's
a really brilliant concept and in the
shadow of the Moon pulls it off really
well by letting you experience things
from the perspective of Thomas Lockhart
played by Boyd Holbrook who we first
meet in 1988 Lockhart is investigating
the attacks carried out by Riya and he
seemingly kills her thus ending the
spring there's something strange about
her though and she seems to know
intimate details about the character and
events that haven't happened yet such as
his daughter being born and his wife and
partners death
flash-forward 9 years later and Riya
appears once more carrying out another
number of murders she's initially
thought to be a copycat
but Lockhart quickly discovers that this
is indeed the person that he met in 1988
and by the time we roll around to 2006
which is when a younger version of Riya
appears Lockhart is completely obsessed
with her this comes at the expense of
his relationship with his daughter and
for Lockhart stopping Riya also means
going back and erasing the timeline that
he's currently stuck in which has made
the relationship with his child
completely frayed now one of the biggest
takeaways from the film at least in my
opinion is that Lockhart never actually
needed to stop Riya in order to have a
relationship with his daughter he just
became so obsessed with her that he was
unable to see anything outside of it and
thus he suffers for a number of decades
before coming to the right conclusion by
the end of the film
anyway after tracking ride to where her
time machine appears and dissapears
Lockhart is able to know the exact
location that Riya will be in in the
future as Riya is only capable of
traveling between spaces of nine years
he is able to wait almost a decade for
her to emerge and he confronts a younger
version of her just before her mission
starts now this is where the big reveal
of the film comes and we discovered that
Riya is actually Lockhart granddaughter
and that he was the person have pretty
much shaped her to become a time
traveller in the future when she was
growing up he was aware of what would
happen to her but knew that if she went
back she would be successful in her
mission of terminating
excuse the pun all of the targets and
thus he pretty much multa into doing it
similar to those who shaved the
terrorists Lockhart has shaped
humanity's Savior and thus he allows
riot to continue on a mission knowing
full well that he will murder a version
of her in 1988 on her final mission now
the biggest question I've seen floating
around about the end of the film is did
Riya complete her mission the answer is
yes but I can understand why there's
some confusion now as we see the office
block explosion from the beginning of
the film that we know led to 11,000
deaths slowly reversing and the flag
disappearing it's a safe bet to assume
that riot did indeed complete her goals
thus the bombings never happened and an
alternate timeline is created leaving
this version of Riya as she refers to
herself as an echo disaster averted
everyone can go on to live a happy life
including Lockhart who was now fully
aware that due to his obsession he has
shattered the relationship with his
daughter and that he has to be there for
her and her child this allows him to
raise Riya the way that he should have
been in the original timeline and almost
make amends for his failings as a father
going forward there will be no need for
the version of Riya to sacrifice herself
and now Lockhart his daughter and his
granddaughter can go on to forge a
relationship together it makes for an
awesome ending and the film as a whole
is great I thoroughly enjoyed this from
start to finish and while some plot
beats are predictable if you've ever
seen a time travel film before the movie
is great at setting rules sticking to
them whilst also telling the rise and
fall of a man that has let his obsession
get the best of him overall it makes for
a great film and though it doesn't
completely knock it out of the park
there are still a lot of things that
make this engaging it doesn't do the
usual Netflix move of completely
battering you over the head with the
message behind it which I massively
appreciate as often these kind of films
can get bogged down completely with
political subtext whereas this seems to
avoid if well enough to make the
storyline enjoyable actually thing in
the shadow of the Moon is the one to
watch this weekend and it's a great
little watch if you've got some time to
kill because because the movies about
people traveling through time and killed
nevermind anyway overall it gets an 8
out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on in the shadow of the moon
and if you enjoyed it and make sure you
let me know in the comment section below
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of the news that spider-man is
officially back in the MCU which will be
linked at the end I go over everything
about the new deal between the two
companies as well as how the two
universes may tie together so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to come
chat to me about movies TV shows games
and comic books then make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition YT
it's the best way to get in touch with
me and it's the perfect place to suggest
new videos and content so hopefully I
see you over there after this also just
wanna let you know that we're currently
giving away a free copy of spider-man
far from home on blu-ray and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on in the shadow of
the Moon in the comments section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the Bureau be
shipped out from then to forget surprise
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is the channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
you
[Music]